au coeur du désert du pérou de
mystérieux dessins sont gravés dans le
sol on les appelle les géoglyphes de
nasca il ne cesse de captiver les
archéologues depuis des années ils sont
classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco depuis 1994 c'est géoglyphes
sont des trésors fragile qui soulève
beaucoup beaucoup de questions peut-être
d'ailleurs que le mitico libre et de
nasca vous dit quelque chose alors que
signifient ces gravures pourquoi
sont-elles là à cet endroit précis quand
ont-elles été réalisés et surtout
comment pour répondre à ses
interrogations je suis accompagné
aujourd'hui de arcana qui parraine ce
quatorzième épisode bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de
cabinet curieuse et aujourd'hui nous
partons en amérique du sud
je suis très heureux de partager ce
voyage avec sa bien bienvenue dans
cabinet curieux
[Musique]
et
nombreux sont les livres les films les
jeux vidéo les séries même les dessins
animés qui ont surfé sur le mystère de
ces géoglyphes indiana jones et le
royaume du crâne de cristal en est un
excellent exemple mettons-nous justement
dans la peau d'un manager
juste pour vous situer il s'agit pas de
juste un ou deux géoglyphes les gravures
qui recouvre le sol de nasca sont
difficiles à chiffrer mais on en a
découvert plus de 1000 ses gravures sont
difficilement visibles à l'oeil nu en
raison de leur grande taille et en
raison du temps qui passe et qui les
haltères pourtant à chaque fouille on en
trouve de nouvelles comme c'était le cas
par exemple en 2019 avec des
scientifiques japonais de l'université
de yamagata qui se sont penchés sur le
site et qui en ont découvert 143
supplémentaires effectivement il ya de
quoi dire à commencer par ce qui est
représenté plantes animaux êtres humains
les chercheurs sont surpris par la
diversité des illustrations et cela crée
un vrai mystère sur le lien qu elles ont
entre est l'une d'entre elles
représentent un grand chat de 37 mètres
de long sur le flanc d'une colline le
ministère de la culture péruvien a
déclaré que la figure était à peine
visible et elle était sur le point de
disparaître parce qu'elle est située sur
une pente assez raide sujette aux effets
de l'érosion naturelle elle a failli
passer inaperçu malgré que ces
réalisations et plusieurs millénaires la
plupart des géoglyphes sont plutôt bien
conservée puisque c'est l'une des
régions les plus sèches au monde et que
le gypse une espèce minérale contenue
dans le sol cole au sable et à la
poussière grâce au faible taux
d'humidité un peu comme la fameuses
araignées qui est plutôt bien conservé
du coup la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est qui a réalisé ces gravures et
quand ce chat serait l'une des plus
anciennes réalisations ce qui explique
son état de conservation mitigé ce
serait le peuple paracas qui en moins
500 à 200 après jésus-christ aurait
réalisé cette gravure il existe bien
d'autres joe beef réalisé par le peuple
basque à entre 200 et 700 après
jésus-christ du coup venons en à la
question qui nous intéresse pourquoi
pourquoi avoir créé des gravures visible
depuis le ciel à une époque où
l'aviation n'est pas du tout d'actualité
quelle est la signification de ces
géoglyphes dans quels intérêts des
peuples se sont donné autant de mal à
les faire
et si je vous disais qu une des réponses
possibles se trouve dans les maths ne
partez pas tout de suite arcana vous
explique pour le mathématicien
l'allemande maria reisch il s'agirait
d'un calendrier astronomique géant dont
les lignes pointe vers les étoiles ou
des constellations à des dates
importantes
les dessins d'animaux seraient une
représentation zodiacale du cosmos un
peu farfelu pensez vous eh bien
figurez-vous que le scientifique paul
kosok a découvert qu'au coucher du
soleil lors du solstice d'été une partie
des longues lignes droites deviennent
parallèle aux rayons du soleil une autre
théorie suggère que ces géoglyphes
aurait un lien avec le chamanisme le
chamanisme est une pratique répandue en
amérique du sud et certaines drogues
donne l'impression de flotter dans les
airs ou de voler du coup cette pratique
permettait de voir les gravures depuis
le ciel en donnant la possibilité aux
chavannes de voir leur animal pouvoir
même si curieusement le peuple pouvait
lui aussi observé les gravures depuis
une simple colis toutes ces théories
sont liées aux astres mais un historien
avance une toute autre théorie pour
l'historien henri sterling il s'agirait
d'heures de tissage géante dédiée à la
fabrication dhabi funéraire alors dit
comme ça ça semble un petit peu étrange
mais il faut savoir que les tissus
mortuaire qu'on a retrouvés dans les
tombes de nascar ont une particularité
celle d'être tisser d'une seule traite
un peu comme des fils sans fin alors ça
pourrait coller parce que pour préparer
ses fils il faut un travail de lignes en
zigzag cette théorie pourrait donc
expliquer la pratique des chemins zigzag
mais ça n'explique pas du tout les 1000
géoglyphes bien détaillé qu'on a
retrouvés une dernière théorie reste en
lien avec le ciel pour les géoglyphes
vue du ciel il pourrait s'agir d'un
message adressé aux divinités tandis que
pour les géoglyphes plus petits ceux qui
sont par groupe la signification
pourraient être liés à l'eau et à la
fertilité
justement pour pallier le manque d'eau
dans la région les peuples avait
développé les riga sion via des puits
souterrains il est possible que les
géoglyphes étaient alors des points de
repère pour retrouver les sources et
peut-être que les peuples solliciter les
divinités pour invoquer leurs besoins
cette théorie est d'ailleurs soutenue
par un citoyen comme vous et moi jacky
galvez un retraité passionné par les
géoglyphes de nasca qui explore depuis
chez lui ces lieux mystérieux grâce à
google earth les parcs blog et pourtant
depuis des années la question le captif
pour lui les géoglyphes ont bien rapport
avec l'eau il partage d'ailleurs ses
découvertes avec de nombreux
archéologues selon ses dires les figures
réalisées à flanc de colline sont reliés
à des bassins ou des puits comme quoi
chaque citoyen peut participer à la
collectivité d'ailleurs dit nous en
commentaires vous en tant que citoyen
que pensez vous que peuvent représenter
ces lignes de nasca un indice vient
appuyer cette théorie du culte de l'eau
l'intensification des géoglyphes colle
avec une période de sécheresse des
hôtels avec des offrandes ont été
identifiés à l'extrémité des géoglyphes
et on peut considérer que ces derniers
étaient des espaces de culte oui des
espaces de culte comme nous nous avons
des lieux de culte pour nous réunir eux
aurait utilisé ses géoglyphes une piste
plutôt cohérente puisque grâce à leur
étude les chercheurs ont constaté que
ces géoglyphes étaient des lieux
d'activités ou l'ina ce cas marchais
lors de processions rituel comment at on
pu prouver que c'est un lieu de culte
deux mille ans plus tard et bien grâce à
la magnétométrie une méthode qui permet
de détecter les anomalies et les
variations du champ magnétique terrestre
grâce à cela les chercheurs ont pu
constater un piétinement massif est
répétée bon vous l'aurez compris on a
quelques pistes sur le pourquoi
maintenant il reste la question du
comment comment ont-ils réaliser de si
beaux et de si grands dessins sans avoir
de vue aérienne comment ces dessins
ont-ils pu rester en place pendant 2000
ans en théorie c'est très simple pour
définir les contours de leur dessein les
peuples déplacer des pierres puis
gratter la couche supérieure de terre
entre les contours en faisant sa une
couche plus clair apparaissait faisant
ainsi ressortir les fameux descente
ce qui est ainsi fou dans cette histoire
c'est la précision des gravures les
contours sont nettes et constitue un
véritable chef-d'oeuvre comment les
nascar ont ils fait sans recul et sans
prendre de hauteur pour avoir un rendu
aussi précis et bien l'aide de cordes et
de point fixe grâce à de longs fils les
peuples tracer ses figures entre ces
points fixes ce qui donne un rendu assez
précis une fois la terre gratter les
géoglyphes ne sont d'ailleurs pas unique
ana cas puisqu'on en retrouve aussi dans
le désert du nord du chili ou en
amérique du nord bref quoiqu'il en soit
ces gravures pose toujours de nombreuses
questions apparemment un film sur le
sujet est en cours de création il
s'appellerait lady nasca le récit
s'inspire de l'histoire vraie de la
fameuse mathématicienne dont parlait
tout à l'heure qui rencontre les figures
de nasca alors qu'elle est en quête de
son chemin de vie le travail de maria
sur les figures de nascar est une
métaphore à son mouvement personnel à sa
quête intime et le film pose plus
généralement la question de sa place
dans le monde alors si le sujet vous
intéresse ouvrez l'oeil il devrait
sortir
[Musique]
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
merci beaucoup arcana doit participer à
cet épisode je vous invite à faire un
tour sur sa chaîne pour découvrir de
nombreuses autres histoires
mythologiques ésotérique archéologiques
mais pas seulement d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup fabien pour cette invitation et
j'espère à tout ce que vous avez passé
un bon moment pensez à laïque et
commenter et partager la vidéo est sur
ce je vous dis à très bientôt si vous ne
connaissiez pas encore je m'appelle
toujours
lire waouh non alors fabien olicard et
si vous êtes tout nouveau ici sur la
chaîne v déjà bienvenue vous pouvez vous
abonner activer la cloche nous dire ce
que vous avez pensé aussi de l'épisode
en commentaire moi ici je vous met deux
autres épisodes c'est le deux précédents
cabinet curieuse et puis si vous êtes
très très curieux en lien dans la
description vous allez trouver mon
magazine sert mensuel un papier depuis
maintenant deux ans et demi qui
reprendra au mois de septembre si vous
abonner maintenant le premier envoi se
fera tout début septembre passé sur le
site vous allez pouvoir lire toutes les
choses qu'on a déjà publié qui sont
directement accessibles prenez soin de
vous à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous